mr. grey will see you now - what do you
owe your success I have a natural
instinct for what makes you a person
tech that sounds like every serial
killer ever
I mean he's fair with her and welcome to
hash tag news
love is in the air and what better way
to celebrate this Valentine's Day than
going out with your loved ones to see a
movie about a rich dude who wants to
make a young college girl sign a
contract that says their relationship
will be purely sexual that's right this
year's big Valentine's Day movie is
fifty Shades of Grey this is the first
year the big movie on Valentine's Day is
not about love I mean let's look back at
some previous Valentine's Day releases
50 first dates The Vow Silence of the
Lambs
bad example I never saw it isn't about
two deaf lambs falling in love no that
means my screenplay is a go I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with whips
and leather in the bedroom whatever
floats your sexy boat but you shouldn't
go see this movie expecting to see two
people fall madly in love it's about a
girl who tries to change herself to
satisfy a man's needs how sweet I don't
know if you guys know this but I
actually auditioned for this movie
[Music]
to who you're into that freaky sex up
aren't you
yeah well I'm gonna go didn't get it but
that's not all folks
first of all the book this movie is
based on is a fanfiction of Twilight
with the same empowering message change
yourself completely to be with a man
barf in my mouth no not really
also have you seen the stars of this
movie together neither of them look like
they want to be within 50 feet of each
other it's been reported that on set
they couldn't stand one another and had
absolutely a new chemistry uh have fun
making sequels together for the next
five years they don't seem too thrilled
about the movie either in an interview
with lammer magazine Dakota Johnson said
there's a part of me that's like I don't
want anyone to see this movie just
kidding oh don't worry Dakota I'm sure
only a handful of people will see this
movie and oh it's getting a worldwide
release and a 4.5 million advance
tickets have already been solved sorry
mrs. Dakota's mom on the other hand
putting this movie out on Valentine's
Day might actually be a genius move to
get all the single ladies in those seats
now I'm not saying that I'm going or
anything but okay yes I'm gonna go see
it this weekend but it's only because I
don't have any other Valentine's Day
plans yet
okay I'm going alone if there are any
single guys out there watching I have
some advice go see this movie by
yourself on Valentine's Day one of two
things will happen either all the girls
in the theater will leave ready to junk
the first guy they see ie you or wait
for she Greg gets really predatory you
could just yell at the screen be a
gentleman you pick she deserves better
and see if you can Lance them digits
well that's it for this edition of hash
tag news like this video if you're also
alone on Valentine's Day
leave a comment with some hashtag news
fanfiction and subscribe for more
hashtag news oh and follow us on Twitter
for all the latest happenings in
internet town
I'm Annie's Fairweather and I'm gonna go
start loading my purse with snacks
because this Valentine's Day no one is
gonna buy me anything at the concession
stand
so you wanna hang out with me analyze it
no